[Musique]
mais l'on débat sur france 24 consacrait
au 6e paquet de sanctions adoptées par
les européens contre la russie les
vingt-sept ont trouvé un accord un
accord qui devrait permettre de réduire
de 80% leurs importations de pétrole
russe avant la fin de l'année l'objectif
c'est bien sûr tahrir le financement de
la guerre menée par moscou en ukraine
l'embargo sur le pétrole sera partielle
dans un premier temps il ne concernera
que l'or noir acheminés par voie
maritime
la hongrie la slovaquie et la république
tchèque continueront à être
approvisionnées par le 'pipeline' russe
droujba ce nouveau paquet de sanctions
va-t-il donc faire plier la russie on va
revenir sur cet accord à vingt-sept sur
ces exceptions sur ses effets alors que
l'inflation dans la zone euro est à 8,1
pour cent l'économie russe
souffre-t-elle de cette sanction ou au
contraire profites t'elle de l'envolée
des prix des hydrocarbures
on parlera aussi du blocus le blocus et
réalisa odessa comment les européens
pourrait-il acheminer des céréales pour
éviter une crise alimentaire mondiale
alors vladimir poutine cédera-t-il face
aux sanctions on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
olivier dorgan bonsoir bonsoir avocat
spécialiste des sanctions économiques au
cabinet ashurst bienvenus en face de
vous nous avons anaa créty bonsoir vous
êtes professeur à paris-dauphine
directrice de la chaire économie du
climat membres du centre de géopolitique
de l'énergie et des matières premières
rattaché au laboratoire d'économie de
dauphine bienvenue également avoue
sylvie matelly est avec nos bons soirs
économistes directrice adjointe de
l'iris auteur de géopolitique de
l'économie c'est aux éditions eyrolles
en face de vous jacques rupnik bonsoir
directeur de recherche à sciences po et
spécialiste de l'europe centrale ancien
conseiller du président tchèque vaclav
havel bienvenue à vous jacques jacques
rupnik alors on va démarrer d'abord on
va redire que les 27 les 27 pays
européens ont effectivement trouvé cet
accord qui devrait permettre de réduire
de 90% leurs importations de pétrole
russe avant de la fin de l'année ils
sont satisfaits emmanuel macron et le
président du conseil offert charles
michel on les écoute
deux principales choses ont été décidés
d'abord un sixième paquet de sanctions
qui est extrêmement important puisqu'il
permet de sanctionner un nouveau coup de
80 oligarques d'interdire et de
sanctionner trois chaînes de télévision
2d swift et comme on le dit c'est à dire
de sortir des systèmes de paiement la
première banque vers banques qui
représentent plus de 35% du marché
aujourd'hui russe et pour la première
fois donc de sanctionner le pétrole
d'avoir du coup une sortie d'ici la fin
de l'année de l'utilisation du pétrole
russe à 92% fans aux machines les
sanctions vont saper le financement de
la machine de guerre russe il y à notre
soutien à l'ukraine avec un soutien
financier et militaire
politique sport mais également
humanitaire et ce week-end et nous nous
engageons auprès d'autres pays pour
qu'ils soutiennent un grève
il est d'ordre vous qui êtes à ce pc des
sanctions peut parler d'embargo
dans un embargo progressif très
clairement on est sur un sujet d'une
manière qui est à l'étude depuis
maintenant près de deux mois on a eu une
premier un premier communiqué de presse
du conseil au début du mois de mai qui
n'a pas été suivie d'effet donc on a vu
des dissensions assez forte entre les
vingt-sept notamment une résistance de
la hongrie et des pays qui n'ont pas
accès au port et donc ils sont très
dépendants de l'acheminement du pétrole
par par oléoduc et donc on n'est pas
dans un embargo immédiat de toute
manière mais comme sur le charbon sur
l'acier où on a été sur des embargos
progressif le charbon a été un embargo
qui rentrera en viron ma doute le
l'acier au mois de juin est donc là on
est dans cette même logique là avec une
date d'entrée sur un embargo qui sera
pareil d'ailleurs total à la fin d'un
deux tiers donc des achats européens ce
qui vient par voie maritime donc pour
tout ce qui touche on va dire les pays
qui ont accès soit la mer baltique sur
le pourtour méditerranéen sur le
pourtour atlantique mais effectivement -
les pays d'europe centrale qui eux sont
beaucoup plus dépendant des canaux
classiques d'oléoducs embargo progressif
jacques qui est jacques rupnik vie est
spécialiste justement il ya les
exceptions hongrie république tchèque
slovaquie est ce que ça veut dire que
les européens n'ont pas réussi à faire
plier victor ban
oui ça y ressemble même viktor orban
avait annoncé la couleur il
il accepterait pas des sanctions qui
priverait son pays parce que son pays
comme très très dépendants du pétrole
mais aussi du gaz russe et plus
généralement toute la politique
énergétique de la hongrie est aligné sur
la russie il fait construire une
centrale nucléaire avec un prêt russe
oui l'énergie hongroise est totalement
dépendante de la russie donc l'idée de
couper du jour langmann non c'était pas
envisageable et donc c'est un vrai
compromis
c'est vrai qu'on n'y a même pas de date
d'après ce que j'ai lu qui oblige à un
moment donné la hongrie à s'y soumettre
on dit quand même que d'ici la fin de
l'année enfin qu'il y aura une nouvelle
réunion au mois de juin et que d'ici la
fin de l'année je crois que la pression
sur orb and less de fort oui elle reste
forte parce que même les deux autres
pays que vous avez mentionné république
tchèque et slovaquie
sont favorables aux sanctions simplement
elles ont des difficultés à la mettre en
oeuvre et donc on va trouver des moyens
pour pallier ce problème là mais elles
sont favorables aux sanctions hors
badwill un problème sur le fond il n'est
pas favorable aux sanctions contre la
russie parce qu'il a un désaccord sur
comportement de l'union européenne par
rapport à la guerre à la cre était
finalement c'est un peu sans la hongrie
que les européens ont pu se mettre
d'accord
dans cet accord et c'est progressif
comme on le disait ma de toute façon il
fallait arriver avec à cet accord avec
l'unanimité donc
ça a été un peu les plus court chemin
probablement pour arriver à
à cette décision collective un peu
arraché mais qui était très importante
pour la crédibilité donc on est au 6e
paquet de sanctions donc il ya une
accumulation de mesures qui vont un peu
crescendo donc pour moi je pense que là
il y a une très très forte signification
politique à ses gestes peut-être un peu
plus encore que celle économique mais on
aura l'occasion de voir quoi politique
pourquoi parce qu'il montre fou même
qu'ils sont unis pour ce paquet de
sanctions qui en a marre des justement à
voir des complots me et avoir un fonds
unique vis-à-vis du moins pour certains
éléments vis-à-vis de la russie mais
mais il ya effectivement quelques
éléments un peu dit son angle sylvie
martelly ces sanctions contre moscou en
fait elle propulse encore plus haut les
prix de l'énergie est ce que c'est cette
ff boomerang en fait de ces sanctions
dont on peut parler en europe
aujourd'hui la hausse des prix de
l'hydro des hydrocarbures alors la
hausse des prix des matières premières
en général mais rappelez-vous ça n'a pas
démarré avec la guerre la guerre n'a
fait qu'amplifier encore parce que
créant de la spéculation puisque les
risques les risques augmentaient sceqe
sanctions à ce qu'elles ne font pas
encore est-ce que nous propulse pas
encore plus franchement ce que je le
prie alors très clairement du brut et de
brent on va voir dans l'est dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent
comment soit appliquer ces sanctions je
pense que ces sanctions ont en partie
été anticipée par les investisseurs et
que les prix ont déjà augmenté en
prévision de narrer moi ce que j'observe
quand même dans ce dernier train de
sanctions déjà quand vous les avez
présenté vous n'avez pas parler de
sanction historique et de trains de
sanctions historique ce qu'on avait fait
sur les premiers trains de sanctions et
surtout les premières parce
qu'effectivement en 48 heures les
européens s'étaient décidés étaient tous
unis et on les sentait véritablement
unique avait peut-être eu des
dissensions sur certains points mais
globalement il y avait quand même il y
avait quand même une position assez
commune là on rentre dans le vif du
sujet et alors que les ambitions le plan
annoncé par l'union européenne pour
progressivement se passer du gaz russe
il ya c'était fin mars me semble-t-il
était quand même très ambitieux avec dix
propositions qui était qui est qui qui
paie qui aurait permis
touché au gaz également d'ici la fin de
l'année n'ont pas plus de gaz là on
s'aperçoit qu'on en parle très très peu
qu'on en parle de moins en moins que
probablement vu qu'on a mis un mois
presque un mois et demi a accepté ce
nouveau train de sanctions avec le
risque jusqu'à cette nuit très tard dans
la nuit que finalement il y ait un
blocage et qui est une désunion qui
apparaissent à la face du monde au
niveau du conseil européen je crois que
là les poteaux un accord a minima tout à
fait est ce que ce que pour revenir à
votre question je pense que les
investisseurs vont se dire bon bah ils
n'y arriveront pas et donc au fond on a
peut-être été trop ambitieux on a
spéculé trop fortement sur le fait que
les européens étaient déterminés ils
sont finalement moins déterminé qu'on
imagine olivier daures quand vous êtes
d'accord avec sylvie matelly quel sera
l'impact des sanctions sur la russie je
peux regarder les chiffres et au final
on a du mal déjà à comprendre à savoir
quel est l'impact des sanctions
actuelles taux de chômage à 4 %
inflation a pratiquement 18 % est-ce que
la russie souffre déjà des sanctions
aujourd'hui alors la russie et 21
poutine a anticipé si sanction il dit
depuis plusieurs mois et ce qui est
assez intéressant c'est qu'il ya des
données économiques qui sont assez
contraire d'une part on a eu la bataille
du rouble qui était un des ans un des
enjeux des contre-mesures russe donc dès
les premiers jours des incursions
militaires sur le territoire ukrainien
vladimir poutine a adopté toute une
série de mesures qui avait pour objectif
de favoriser maximiser la circulation du
rouble pour faire remonter son cours est
donc aujourd'hui dans sa communication
interne en fait c'est un outil de
communication pour le dire booty-isme
regardez regardez nous avons une devise
forte il faut savoir que ces mesures
sont des mesures qui sont assez
artificiel et que donc peut être
potentiellement dans quelques mois voire
dans quelques années le cours du rouble
retrouverait le court qu'il devrait
avoir une fois que ces mesures n'auront
plus d'effet sur l'économie on est sûr
en temps qui n'est pas le même que le
temps du droit les sanctions sont
adoptées rapidement ce qui est assez
inédit ça pour le coup on peut souligner
à l'exception de ce train de sanctions
mais on est sur un temps long ces
mesures elle n'entre pas en vigueur
immédiatement pour certaines ya des taux
des périodes de transition donc les
premières sont donc c'est normal que
pour l'instant lorsqu'on regarde les
chiffres macro mais la russie on
al'impression les chiffres ne sont pas
bons une inflation à presque 20 % on est
quand même presque trois fois au dessus
de l'inflation la zone européenne on est
sur une récession anticipé qui est
potentiellement plus grande que celle de
98 donc la russie est quand même sur le
bord du précipice d'un point de vue
économique c'est si vous dites on a
parlé aussi de défaut de paiement gore
qui a été retardé donc il a été retardé
c'est ça est ce que jacques rupnik vous
pensez vous que cet embargo va faire
plier moscou il ce sixième paquet avec
les autres noms n'a jamais vu un embargo
des sanctions économiques avoir un effet
immédiat et surtout arrêter une guerre
par exemple non je ne le pense pas
pourquoi parce qu'ils disent tous ça on
va arrêter de financer cette guerre avec
thé avec vonn à elle de financer et ont
contraint le pays on limite ses
ambitions et du coup ça suscite au sein
de l'élite russe ensuite un débat sur la
poursuite de la guerre sur les objectifs
à atteindre
sur wii de la ce moment là on favorise
disons c'est c'est pas un levier direct
c'est un levier indirecte mais qui peut
être très efficace simplement il faut
s'installer dans la durée comme ça a été
dit ces sanctions produiront de l'effet
dans les prochaines semaines avec
créteil vous êtes d'accord bah disons
qu'on a un exemple historique à léon
subi des sanctions pendant des années
sur le pétrole et c'est pas pour autant
qu'il a disparu de la scène économique
malheureusement tout et tout dépend de
la solution du conflit
la façon dont 1 introduit ces sanctions
laisse vraiment présager un conflit sur
la durée et c'est cette guerre d'usure
d'une partie et de l'autre la frontière
qui qui va être joué donc certes
l'europe
augmente ou élargies les sanctions les
problèmes c'est que les russes ont quand
même la possibilité encore aujourd'hui
de riposter mère justement sylvie
matelly est ce que l'europe ne
souffre-t-elle est ce qu'elle ne
souffre-t-elle f pardon est ce qu'elle
ne souffre pas justement de ce nouveau
train de mesures encore plus que la
russie à court terme parce qu'elles sont
finalement les alternet il faut importer
du gaz naturel de différents pays donc
faut négocier avec eux c'est plus cher
c'est une inflation qui aujourd'hui déjà
à 8,1 pour cent dans la zone euro donc
cet effet boomerang est ce qu'il n'est
pas plus dissuasif encore pour l'europe
c'est toute la difficulté qu'a l'europe
au fur et à mesure des trains de
sanctions à aller plus loin et à imposer
de nouvelles sanctions et en particulier
à aller sur ce qui ferait vraiment mal à
vladimir poutine c'est à dire limiter
voire arrêter les importations de gaz et
de pétrole c'est que là on touche le
coeur du réacteur c'est que là ça va
nous faire très très mal dans un
contexte où il ya déjà vous l'avez
rappelé beaucoup d'inflation où il ya un
problème de pouvoir d'achat partout en
europe des débuts de questionnements là
dessus mais d'ailleurs vladimir poutine
ne s'y étaient pas trompés parce que
c'est quelque chose qui avait fait
remarquer avec un certain cynisme au
début des cours du conflit c'est que la
population russe était probablement bien
plus résiliente aux difficultés
économiques que les populations
européennes olivier damgan d'ailleurs
lorsqu'on voit la russie et bien ils ont
coupé le gaz russe justement la
livraison du gaz russe aux pays bas
peut-être au danemark la pologne
également donc on voit bien que c'est
tout de même à double tranchant c'est à
dire que vladimir poutine utilise aussi
cette arme du gaz mais c'était l'autre
côté ça a été un des freins
effectivement une des toutes premières
réactions de certains pays qui sont
beaucoup plus dépendant que nous le
sommes nous en france du gaz russe c'est
dire si on met la question du pétrole
sur la table des sanctions on risque de
voir la russie nous menacer de couper de
pétrole et tout au long du mois de mars
parce que ce débat de l'embargo sur le
pétrole il est il est assez ancien
finalement il est arrivé assez
rapidement et on a eu des trains de
sanctions qui ont été adoptés quasiment
de manière hebdomadaire jusqu'au milieu
du mois de mars après on a eu chaud
jusqu'au début du mois d'avril et là on
est à la fin du mois de mai et donc des
débuts de me dès le mois de mars on
parlait d'un embargo sur le pétrole et
les résistances de certains pays et est
dire si on on en imposant un embargo sur
le pétrole on risque effectivement de
voir la russie nous couper les vannes de
gaz et on a vu d'ailleurs l'utilisation
par la russie de l'instrument du gaz
notamment au monde de l'adhésion de la
demande d'adhésion de la finlande puis
de la suède à l'otan on voit
immédiatement la riposte heureuse c'est
à dire très bien voulait adhérer à
l'otan on vous coupe cette ressource
dont vous avez terriblement besoin
carrière isaac robin et qu'elle soit
n'est pas un bras de fer l'absolu mans
mais ce bras de fer d'abord il dépend
pas seulement des mesures économiques
qui sont prises et dépend
la capacité politique des européens à
rester unis dépend aussi de l'évolution
de la guerre sur le terrain parce que
faut quand même rappeler qu initialement
poutine avait prévu une guerre éclair là
on est plus de 3 mois il n'a pas obtenu
les objectifs escomptés on s'installe
dans une guerre longue durée et voilà
c'est là que le bras de fer que vous
mentionnez aura lieu mais il faut
s'installer dans la durée est ce que les
européens ont cette capacité de durer de
s'installer dans la durée ça on le verra
parce que il était très unie au départ
on voit quelques fissures apparaître et
d'ailleurs les fissures ils
n'apparaissent pas forcément sur les
sanctions bien sûr on a vu hors ban qui
s'est singularisé mais apparaissent
aussi sur l'attitude face à la russie
sur les objectifs de guerre
quel est l'objectif qu'elle est là
quelle est l'issue du conflit là on voit
des fissures apparaître donc c'est tout
ça qui va jouer dans la capacité
européenne à soutenir ces sanctions dans
la durée et en en supporter les
conséquences parce que vous avez bien
dit que c'est un boomerang c'est bien
sûr que ça allait retomber sur sur nos
sociétés sur impact sur l'inflation et
accessoires d'achat donc en europe anna
créty justement vous qui êtes
spécialiste de l'énergie est ce que
véritablement l'europe peut devenir
indépendante sur le pétrole déjà ne
serait-ce que ce par rapport au pétrole
russe est ce que c'est déjà le cas
aujourd'hui
ils ont les alternatives aujourd'hui les
européens donc il s'agit un grand de
trouver 3 millions de barils par jour
trois millions de barils par jour j'ai
vu que c'est l'équipe 4 81 milliards de
dollars c'est ça c'est qu'on paye
globalement c'est qu'on a payé d'humains
on va dire la facture payée à la russie
pour les importations de pétrole l'année
dernière sachant que c'était une année
un peu particulière donc un peu plus on
va dire un peu plus élevé que la moyenne
alors là on a du pétrole dans le monde
soit qu'ils aient qui est déjà dans les
chaînes de production soit qu'il est
qu'ils soient sous terre ou dans les
rochers donc donc c'est l'alternative de
ce à quoi les américains les prem's et
qu'il ne faudrait pas donner enfin c'est
complètement en contradiction avec la
transition énergétique
on donne des l'incitation à
extraire du pétrole alors qu'on veut
s'en passer mais il faudra le faire si
on veut pas subir des ruptures
d'approvisionnement
donc toute la question c'est comment on
concilie un objectif dont on ne connaît
pas en fait la durée jusqu'à quand on
aura des sanctions de jusqu'à caen devra
se priver du pétrole russe tout en
disant on fait la transition énergétique
donc on veut enlever de toute façon se
passer de pétrole et c'est
contradictoire vous l'avez dit donc
c'est compliqué oui mais il y a du
pétrole dans les mandats dont convient
faut aller les chercher alors justement
où les européens vont-ils leur tour le
trouvait aux états unis où c'est les
émirats les premiers à cataroux commencé
puisqu'il faut quand même l'un portait
et que ça coûte cher parce que ils
arrivent par bateau mais les bateaux il
faut les payer donc ce sera plus cher
jusque là c'est plus cher mais il faut
aller chercher par en indien par bassins
de proximité on va commencer à négocier
et tous les 27 pays vont aller chercher
chez les mêmes
norvège
algérie aux nigériens ces deux dernières
sondes à l'opecst donc ne sont pas
complètement l'hymne de leur action et
on passe aux autres grandes puissances
justement de l'opecst l'arabie saoudite
et les émirats donc cesser ces pays là
qui vont avoir l'équilibré mondial du
pétrole et ils ont aucun intérêt
d'ouvrir la reproduction et de faire
baisser les prix c'est ça donc justement
pour en revenir à l'inflation est-ce que
l'impact sur l'inflation plus globale
sylvie matelly va être très important
avec cette redéfinition aussi à la fois
géopolitique et économique en fait de la
livraison de pétrole en europe mais y
avoir une montée des prix alors il va y
avoir une montée des prix très
clairement mais au delà de l'inflation
ce qui se dessine aujourd'hui c'est et
au delà de l'inflation sur les sur les
produits énergétiques sur le pétrole et
sur le gaz ce qui a le plus gros risque
aujourd'hui qui se dessine c'est quand
même le risque de de cherté des denrées
alimentaires voire de pénurie d'un vent
par les terres et là c'est encore autre
chose c'est que s'il s'agit pas de
l'essence qu'on met dans sa voiture
s'agit de l'alimentation et de la survie
d'un certain nombre de personnes jacques
rivette juste un mot kiev n'a pas couper
le transit du gaz russe par l'oléoduc
d'ailleurs qui passe par l'ukraine vous
avez une explication à cela il aurait pu
le faire
d'abord c'est du gaz qui va vers des
partenaires européens dont on espère le
soutien donc ça c'est une première chose
deuxièmement c'est une source de revenus
considérables pour parce que on est en
guerre mais le le coût du transit il est
quand même payer c'est une ressource
importante pour l'ukraine et c'est toute
la contradiction la contradiction
puisque aujourd'hui évidemment on a
entendu le président ukrainien qu'il est
très content de ce paquet de sanctions
européennes oui bien sûr il content de
toutes les mesures qui visent à couper
l'union européenne économiquement et
politiquement de la russie tout bien
entendu politiquement c'est très
important pour lui mais ça n'empêche pas
en attendant de le servir de transit
pour le gaz russe le lui qui s'appelle
droujba qui veut dire l'amitié et de
l'amitié on est en guerre
et ont fait transiter ont fait transiter
on va continuer à faire transiter donc
pas graisseux 6e paquet on va continuer
à faire transiter ce gaz par bruce bad
donc on va le voir sur la carte on avait
dit à la hongrie mais aussi à la
république tchèque est aussi à la
slovaquie donc et en fait ils disent
qu'ils seront clavé que c'est la raison
pour laquelle il faut continuer ils
n'ont pas accès
sauf assembler polonais peuvent avoir
accès au gaz liquéfié sur la soul sur la
mer baltique il ya des installations
pour ça donc pour la pologne c'était
plus facile en un sens de de
se priver du gaz russe et certains le
font aussi parce que politiquement il
considère que c'est une priorité absolue
des pays baltes étaient très dépendants
et ils sont très déterminés à couper
donc parfois la volonté politique est
plus important que les intérêts
économiques immédiats bien d'autres pays
comme la hongrie qui disent non notre
intérêt économique la stabilité de nos
prix assurée par le deal que j'ai fait
avec poutine dira hörmann c'est ce qui
lui a permis d'ailleurs de remporter un
succès aux élections
il n'a pas joué la carte du soutien à
l'ukraine il a joué la carte de la
stabilité des prix en hongrie et ça a
été payant ça a été payant alors
justement les russes on en a un petit
peu parlé de cette arme alimentaire il
utilise en tout cas avec ce blocus
céréaliers à odessa les européens on
discute encore ils en ont discuté
aujourd'hui de comment justement essayer
de contourner ce blocus est ce que les
européens pourraient justement acheminer
ces céréales et contourner cette ce
blocus on va écouter le chef de la
diplomatie russe sergueï lavrov
les pays occidentaux qui ont créé
beaucoup de problèmes superficiel en
fermant leurs ports aux navires us en
perturbant les chaînes logistiques et
financières doivent sérieusement
réfléchir à ce qui est le plus important
pour eux soit faire de la communication
sur la question de la sécurité
alimentaire soit prendre des mesures
concrètes pour résoudre ce problème
olivier daures quand on voit bien toute
l'ambiguïté puisque là c'est quoi ce
qu'on peut appeler ça un chantage un
chantage aux céréales du côté russe oui
alors c'est clairement un chantage
jusque de manière beaucoup plus claire
vladimir poutine a effectivement appelé
de ses voeux
la levée des sanctions comme comme
potentiel moyen de réapprovisionner
comme la plupart du blé mondial les
produits enfin une grande partie du blé
mondial et produits sont d'ukraine soit
sur le territoire russe notamment
d'ailleurs depuis des sanctions 2014 qui
on conseillera de considérablement
renforcer l'agriculture russe et on en
parle peu mais ce dont on voit un peu ce
à quoi il est fait allusion dans dans
cet extrait vidéo c'est le fait que les
sanctions visent également le secteur de
transport et ça on en a peu parlé mais
c'est vrai que dans les trains de
sanctions précédent on a interdit d'une
part par exemple transport routier russe
dalle accès au territoire européen avec
notamment des scènes absolument
apocalyptique à la frontière polonaise
aux alentours du 15 et du 16 mai quand
date de l'entrée en vigueur de ce décès
de cette interdiction on a également une
interdiction d'accès au port pour les
bateaux on a une interdiction de
l'espace aérien et donc c'est vrai ça
c'est lié aux fonctions les sanctions en
fête européenne en fait isole
complètement la réussite de ces canaux
de communication et de transport
habituel donc mais bloquent le port
d'odessa donc eu beau leur histoire de
dessin certes mais nous nous interdisons
par exemple d'utiliser des navires
russes pour affréter le cas échéant des
produits alimentaires ou des
transporteurs routiers par exemple donc
en fait il ya une forme de dodo d'effet
boomerang là aussi sur ces sanctions
parce qu'on décide d'isoler d'un point
du canot de transport complètement la
russie de notre de l'europe et d'une
partie du monde de fait et en
contrepartie et henry en résultat on se
prive aussi d'un moyen d'avoir accès à
des ressources notamment des denrées
alimentaires qui sont très importants de
produits de manière très importante sur
le territoire russe et une partie du
territoire kényan c'est toute la
contradiction anna chrétiens alors
comment les européens pourrait-il
éventuellement obtenir un deal à on
parle d'un deal avec la turquie ça sera
entre la russie la turquie pour
acheminer une partie à des céréales les
européens pour l'instant ne parviennent
pas à se mettre d'accord comment
pourrait-il essayer justement de
contourner ce blocus disons que sur les
céréales
aussi un double problème parce qu'il y à
la production russe et la production
ukraine
donc les deux sont glauques et ont même
un droit et un plus avec la guerre c'est
sûr que on a une très mauvaise prévision
sur l'année prochaine parce que c'est
sans doute la dernière des
préoccupations de s'occuper de la
récolte forcément c'est de la récolte
après de blé troisième problème il ya de
la sécheresse un peu partout donc c'est
sûr que ce sont des denrées qu'on peut
stocker mais jusqu'à un certain moment
donc pour moi le seul argument c'est que
si ces denrées n'arrive pas sortir en
temps et en heure
et un gros on ne pourra plus les
utiliser donc encore une fois l'idée
c'est de dire bon si vous voulez quand
même avoir une forme plus ou moins de
revenus pour honorer des contrats déjà
existants il faut le faire sortir et les
faits les acheminer vers la destination
finale donc avant qu' elle soit
complètement inutilisable jacques rupnik
est ce qui pourrait arriver à un accord
vous pensez les européens pour essayer
de contourner ce blocus sur les céréales
j'ai cru comprendre que le président
français avait communiqué avec poutine
pour justement essayer de débloquer le
port d'odessa et permettre à des fins
qui ne concerne pas les européens ni les
russes mais permettre aux pays d'afrique
principalement
d'être d'être fournie mais elle vous
paraît pas sans succès pour l'instant
cette discussion et venelles macromedia
le succès n'est pas assuré c'est que ça
n'est pas vrai c'est ce qui c'est une
des justifications pour les coups de fil
parce que soit dit en passant les coups
de fil avec poutine ça passe mal auprès
de certains européens surtout ceux de
l'est donc là il ya une justification
qui est importante il peut y avoir des
raisons humanitaires un corridor pour
évacuer les populations de mario paul je
sais pas et là il ya une raison qui est
vraiment importante et qui ne concerne
ni les européens ni la russie mais qui
concerne des pays qui d'ailleurs se sont
abstenus pour la plupart dans le vote
aux nations unies sur la guerre donc ça
c'est intéressant parce que ça les
ex-soldats véricel pas dire qu il prouve
la guerre ça veut dire simplement il
refuse de prendre parti dans ce conflit
entre occidentaux et la russie et donc
ce sont ces pays là qui sont les
premiers concernés par
l'arrivée
du
du blé de russie et d'ukraine sylvie
matelly c'est vrai que le monde est un
petit peu suspendue à ses cette
problématique du blocus des céréales
parce qu'effectivement risques de famine
en afrique est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir
un accord on parle éventuellement d'un
accord entre la russie et la turquie qui
pourrait faire justement acheminer une
partie des céréales alors j'en sais rien
mais en tout cas on ne peut que le
souhaiter mais ça n'enlève ça n'enlève
rien au fait que il ya plusieurs il ya
d'autres problématiques et ça a été
évoqué déjà ces pays touchés ou qui sont
en risque se sont opposés aux sanctions
occidentales parce qu'ils avaient déjà
anticipé les conséquences que cela
pourrait avoir et qu'ils sont en train
de vivre et qui vont s'empirer dans les
mois qui viennent l'augmentation des
prix de l'énergie des prix des denrées
alimentaires les risques de pénurie du
fait de ces sanctions et c'est avec ce
je crois que c'est le président du
sénégal qui avait dit mais au fond vous
vous faites ce que vous voulez en
matière de relations internationales
vous sanctionnez vous décidez et puis à
la fin c'est nous qui en payons le prix
fort donc voilà pourquoi on adopte cette
posture là donc ça c'est quelque chose
de très important mais au delà de la
russie et de l'ukraine la russie et
l'ukraine c'est 30% je crois de la
production mondiale de blé dont ça veut
dire qu'il ya 70% dans le reste du monde
mais surtout ce qui est certain c'est
que les productions agricoles partout
dans le monde sont fortement affaibli
par des tas de facteurs la question du
changement climatique et la sécheresse
en climat lié en a parlé la sécheresse
la question des politiques agricoles
aussi faut pas oublier que depuis une
trentaine d'années on a incité un
certain nombre de pays d'afrique et
d'asie à faire des a lancé les cultures
plutôt d'exportation que de
l'agriculture vivrière donc aujourd'hui
sont entièrement dépendant pour
s'alimenter de leur implantation donc
c'est tout un système en fait qui est
questionné ce système qu on appelle
souvent la mondialisation on retrouve ce
sujet ce débat sur le pétrole et le gaz
on retrouve ce sujet ce débat sur les
questions agricoles
la retrouver sur les questions des
médicaments au moment de la crise du
collège donc on s'aperçoit et vous
parliez au tout début de votre
questionnement sur ces sujets de ce que
ça nous dit sur la géopolitique et sur
la reconfiguration du monde ça nous en
dit très long en fait mais c'est en quoi
est ce que ça veut dire que finalement
on n'aurait pas dû les prendre ces
sanctions quand on voit effectivement à
la fois l'effet boomerang à la fois
effectivement un certain nombre de pays
non-alignés en afrique il dit c'est pire
pour nous avec cette crise alimentaire
pour répondre à cette question il faut
regarder en fait l'histoire des
sanctions ces quinze dernières années il
ya eu un glissement très nette dans la
géopolitique qui a vu en fait une
diminution en tout cas de l'appétence de
beaucoup de pays occidentaux aux
interventions militaires notamment aux
suites débâcle américains en irak en
afghanistan à l'impopularité que ça a pu
créer notamment aux états unis et même
en angleterre où et dans certains pays
qui ont contribué fortement à ses
efforts de guerre et on a vu
parallèlement à ça une augmentation
significative du recours aux fonctions
notamment depuis le début de l'année
2010 avec 2014 la crise au venezuela et
ce qui est assez intéressant c'est que
dans n'avions pas le choix en fait je
pense que pour répondre à cette question
soit nous ne faisons rien nous ne
pouvions clairement pas aller sur une le
terrain militaire et ça c'est quelque
chose que l'otan a tout de suite balayé
coq en effet l augmentation
effectivement tout de même de la
livraison ces matériels à oran où que le
comité gérant donc dès lors que nous ne
voulions pas l'être et c'est une il y
avait un consensus pour dire on est
démocraties occidentales pour ne pas
intervenir militairement en ukraine la
seule alternative qui s'offrait à nous
occidentaux s'étaient ces sanctions
effectivement et d'ailleurs ce qui est
intéressant c'est dans la toute première
prise de parole emmanuel macron je crois
que c'était le jour de l'invasion puis
ensuite deux jours après celle de
l'agriculture emmanuel macron a tout de
suite rappelé qu on rentrait dans une
logique de guerre et que dans une
logique de guerre de toute manière
toutes ces meutes ou ses effets
m'ouvrant dont on parle depuis une
vingtaine de minutes étaient des choses
que nous devrions supporter comme nous
avions supporté par le passé l'envoi de
troupes et que des générations de jeunes
hommes ont été envoyés sur le front d'un
des dents y ait un certain nombre
d'années en l'occurrence les aspects
économiques sont malheureusement une
conséquence que nous devrons supporter
nous n'avions pas le choix que d'adopter
est ce que c'est plus morale ou est-ce
que c'est plus économique est ce qu'on
prend c'est sans son on vous dit on n'a
pas le choix parce que c'est une sorte
d'obligation morale aussi voir ce qu
effectivement lorsque charles michel dit
ça va je dirais tahrir le nerf de la
guerre c'est à dire en fait tahrir
l'économie russe est-ce que c'est
efficace ce sont les deux en même temps
c'est à dire qu'il ya une posture
politique qui est très forte et qui est
nécessaire et sur laquelle nous n'avons
effectivement qu'une pas de marche
vraiment de marge de manoeuvre et après
il ya la question d'économie et l'action
de l'économie ce qui est compliqué a
effectivement entendre c'est que c'est
comme on l'a dit à plusieurs reprises ce
soir c'est quelque chose qui prend du
temps parce qu'on on ne se coupe pas de
relation commerciale établie avec un
pays comme la russie qui est quand même
un partenaire privilégié dans grand
nombre de pays européens du jour au
lendemain et donc le temps que ces
mesures commencent à faire effet le
temps que l'économie russe on commence à
démontrer a montré des signes en fait
des faiblissement ont plusieurs mois
voire une année vont s'écouler est donc
là on est dans une temporalité on a de
l'immédiateté de la guerre et en même
temps d'un instrument juridique qui
prend du temps à produire des effets
économiques jacques rueff nez il faut
les faire ces sanctions il fallait faire
faudrait pas c'est d'ailleurs au
septième au 7e paquet de sanctions
envers hockey où il fallait faire bon je
sais pas quel sera le septième paquet
mais il fallait absolument le faire
parce que à cette époque était
simplement dire je condamne la guerre
naturellement nous ne ferons rien parce
que nous n'avons pas d'obligation par le
cren ne fait pas partie de l'otan il n'y
a pas d'article 5 qui s'applique donc on
peut pas on va pas intervenir
et on regarde les spectateurs n'ont donc
il y avait là d'humanitaire d'abord
l'aide aux réfugiés l'aide militaire et
il y a les sanctions économiques qui est
quand même l'union européenne c'est
comme une puissance économique
on a beaucoup ironisé sur la faiblesse
de l'union européenne comme acteur
stratégique
il n'y a pas deux y'a pas de puissance
militaire de l'union européenne par
contre c'est une puissance économique et
quand cette puissance économique agit
même si elle en subit les conséquences
ça des effets qui ne se produisent pas
tout de suite mais qui à terme vont
pousser la russie a changé alors changé
dans quelle direction ça ne le savons
pas parce que les effets des sanctions
on peut on peut espérer qu'elles vont
contraindre les choix de la russie elles
peuvent aussi l'orienter vers un
resserrement des liens avec la chine et
sénateurs d'autres scénarios qui sont
possibles pour la russie à la critique
bah disons que par 10 par rapport à ce
qui a été décidé la margot russie y
avait quand même une alternative du
point de vue économique et technique qui
était celle d'imposer un droit de douane
à spécifique au gaz au pétrole russe
cela aurait quelque part laissé un peu
l'équilibré tel qu'il est et ça aurait
un peut générer on va dire des revenus
supplémentaires qu'on aurait pu affecter
soir des décisions d investissement pour
la transition énergétique soit
éventuellement pour des aides spéciales
à l'ukraine le problème c'est que quand
on touche l'instrument
taxation en europe il ya tout une forme
de critique qui est des négociations et
de loi qu'on arrive difficilement à
toucher on a décidé donc pour cette
forme d'un embargo partiel l'autre
question c'est est-ce que ça va avoir un
effet pour ce qui concerne encore une
fois le pétrole pour la même raison nous
européens on a dit on va aller chercher
ailleurs ben la justice va les vendre
ailleurs c'est ça le vent ailleurs elle
le vend plus cher puisque les
hydrocarbures et alors je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas parce que bon les chinois
sont quand même des redoutables
négociateurs et vous négoce sera belle
pétrole orly vont jamais oui mais donc
oui dira un différentiel de prix mais
les pétroles et anne ont à nouveau il va
être le produit exporté également si
l'uimm était effectivement les russes
vont souffrir de ces il fallait les
prendre ces sanctions ça quelque chose
de dissuasif ou pas je crois que ça a
été dit on n'avait pas on n'avait pas
vraiment le choix et puisqu'on était
déterminée a condamné cette agression
fallait déterminer jusqu'au bout les
russes eux vont souffrir la question qui
se pose à présent c'est quelle va être
leur attitude dans cette souffrance
c'est que le risque des sanctions on
l'avait vu en 2014 on le perçoit encore
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on n'a pas accès à
la communication qui est diffusée aux
russes diversifier leur économie en tout
cas c'est ce qu'ils vont bien déjà
universitaire en économie mais c'est
surtout que ça a tendance à stimuler un
certain nationalisme stimuler un certain
patriotisme a renforcé la popularité du
pouvoir en place on l'a vu dans tous les
régimes de sanctions que ce soit en iran
en russie en 2014 aux autres et là c'est
le risque en fait parce que à l'issue de
cette guerre puisqu'elle aura un jour
une issue dans quelle configuration sur
nous est ce que ce ne seront pas ce ne
sera pas nous qui seront les plus isolés
en réalité alors justement le dernier
paquet de mesures de sanction dont on
parle du loup disais depuis plusieurs
semaines mais ça sera donc le septième
me concerne le gaz russe alors ce
sanctions sur le gaz russe olivier
damgan vous y croyez les européens pour
aller jusque là il faut rappeler quand
même que les européens ont pris
l'engagement à la fin du mois de mars
comme le rappelait si du mat et lit de
se sortir d'une dépendance à hauteur de
deux tiers du gaz russe alors on voit
aujourd'hui que c'était en veut pour
l'instant à ces pieux parce que les
négociations patinent un petit peu sur
la manière d'aboutir à ces objectifs là
rappelons rappelons le le l'objectif il
est aux alentours de deux tiers 80 pour
son emmanuel macron 10 92% pour les
banques ont à peu près sur les mêmes
pétrole c'est beaucoup plus facile
semble-t-il oui parce que le gaz c'est
toute une économie qui est beaucoup plus
coûteuse parce que le gaz est pour le
transporter il faut le liquéfier pour
liquéfier faut avoir une technologie au
départ et une technologie de
regazification à l'arrivée et il faut
des méthaniers ou des gazoducs les
gazoducs et les méthaniers coûte
excessivement cher ce sont des
infrastructures qui sont longues à
mettre en place et donc de fait une
sortie du gaz russe est beaucoup plus
complexe et à mettre en oeuvre que les
une sortie du pétrole sont sous par
ailleurs les sources d'approvisionnement
alternatives sont peut-être un petit peu
plus grande en tout cas dans une
immédiateté donc est ce qu'on y croit
est ce que j'y crois personnellement je
ne sais pas après de toute manière on
est dans une logique de transition de
notre dépendance énergétique et là aussi
je pense que cette crise qu'elle a mis
en avant c'est aussi le fait que nous
européens étions très vulnérable par
rapport à un pays qu'est la russie ou
dont on connaît certains de travers
depuis depuis de nombreuses années et
donc qu'on est en or bargot sur le gaz
ou qu'on n'est pas d'embargo sur le gaz
qui sauvent total ou progressif de toute
manière on est en train de
progressivement sortir de cette relation
de dépendance c'est d'accord décret très
progressivement alors alors est-ce qu
effectivement pour mettre en place un
embargo sur le gaz je pense qu'on n'y
arrivera pas pour les gaz est trop trop
compliqué trop dépendant aux
infrastructures par rapport au début de
la guerre on a quand même augmenté les
importations déjà de 2 m de gaz liquéfié
donc on a déjà mieux faire de ce côté là
alors si on peut fêter le jury vient sur
mon propos initial on peut essayer
d'accélérer vraiment la transition
énergétique là effectivement ça ça
serait la meilleure solution
ça va coûter cher c'est ça le à l'écouté
et diminuer la température
utilisez les thermostats un peu
un peu moins fort
mais c'est la vie la vitesse
des circulations des voitures ça coûte
pas cher au contraire ça ça donne de la
sobriété énergique mais oui mais c'est
là où on est gagnant sauf que ça alors
on a parlé de problèmes
d'infrastructures il ya un gros
changement derrière qui les soutient les
comportements j'ai pense que c'est
presque plus difficile de changer un
comportement que de construire une
infrastructure malheureusement donc
c'est il faut continuer à soutenir cette
idée que certes il faut faire c'est un
seul sortent des chicken
partie on se prive mais on va les
chercher ailleurs mais globalement les
usages des hydrocarbures reste mais si
on diminue la taille du gâteau on sait
ramener tous jacques je crois qu'il ya
un pays clé pour la question vous avez
posé c'est l'allemagne parce que c'est
l'allemagne qui était la plus dépendante
qui a construit north stream 1 puis
north stream 2 il ya eu tout un
consensus politique en allemagne qui
s'écrit qui était d'ailleurs qui
existait déjà avant la chute du mur mais
qui s'est consolidée par la suite le
chancelier schröder gasprom
angela merkel 14 ans au pouvoir elle a
continué sur la même lancée donc là le
consensus était là or l'allemagne est en
train de revoir de fond en comble sa
politique et sa dépendance énergie n'est
pour l'instant elle ne pourrait pas se
passer de gaz et troisième russe elle
peut pas s'en passer du jour au
lendemain mais c'est un c'est un
tournant essentiel de même que le
tournant sur la livraison d'armes jamais
l'allemagne n'aurait envisagé de livrer
des armes à un pays en guerre et surtout
en guerre contre la russie à cause de la
deuxième guerre mondiale et toute la
mémoire que cela charrie relais donc là
il ya un vrai tournant l'allemagne et
sur la question énergétique et sur le
gaz oui ce coupé de north stream 2 c les
allemands qu'ils ont voulu et l'enjeu
sera le vrai test
le jour où north stream ii sera arrêté
sylvie matelly ce qui pourrait justement
ce qui fait que ça fonctionne pas il ya
le politique et puis il ya aussi
l'impact le coup parce que les allemands
est ce qu'ils vont accepter plus de
dette européenne est ce qu'ils vont
accepter c'est ça le problème comment on
va financer à la fois cette transition
énergétique et puis toutes ces sanctions
enfin toutes les alternatives ces
sanctions alors sur le plus de dettes
européennes financement de ces sanctions
ou des conséquences de ces sanctions je
ne pense pas que ce soit les allemands
qui seront les plus difficiles à
convaincre rappelez vous comment sur
l'emprunt manifestement et donc pas
l'air en tout cas ils ont remise des
finances qui a séduit assez dur mais
rappelez-vous ce qui s'était passé au
moment du pot vide avec angela merkel
mais au delà de l'alouette vous avez un
certain nombre de pays ce qu'on a appelé
en son temps j'ai en juillet 2020 les
pays frugaux qui voyaient déjà d'un très
mauvais oeil le plan de relance
européens qui ont l'imaginent vont voir
donner encore plus mauvais de
d'éventuels financements de rallonge de
ce plan de relance ou d'investissement
dont ils ne voient pas les contreparties
en réalité donc ça va être un vrai
france à ça risque d'être un vrai frein
en tout cas une négociation va être très
très difficile et pourtant il faut bien
les financer ces sanctions olivier doran
et ses alternatives cette transition
énergétique en fait la facture pour
l'europe et à 9 milliards d'ailleurs des
dalles ukraine qui ont été décidées
aujourd'hui là on parle de 80 milliards
c'est bien ça sur le coup effectivement
que représente juste le pétrole russe si
en plus on fait les sanctions sur le gaz
il faudra financer tout ça il faut le
financer mais encore une fois je reviens
à ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
c'est la posture géopolitique que nous
avons décidé de de maintenir nous
souhaitons dans les relations
géopolitiques nous entretenons avec des
pays hostiles utiliser cette arme
économique et cette arme elle a
effectivement des conséquences sur nos
économies qui seront assez lourdes qui
sont potentiellement très impopulaire
aussi ça a été derrière un des enjeux de
la campagne présidentielle on l'a vu à
partir du mois de mars on a vu déjà
dedans dans les oppositions emmanuel
macron des critiques sur terre une des
raisons pour lesquelles le pouvoir
d'achat est revenu de manière aussi
forte dans la campagne présidentielle
française et qu'il est d'ailleurs aussi
présent dans l'anc et mène des 17,6 en
france et donc nous n'avons pas le choix
là peut-être lassé de la limite ça sera
la limite de l'adhésion populaire assez
à ces mesures et sur toile à leurs
effets économiques forts
sur la france et sur des membres de
l'union européenne la critique
mcteague disons que il faut quand même
puisqu'il s'agit de sanctions
économiques il faut en même temps
discuter quelles sont les politiques
d'accompagnement qui peuvent du moins
atténuer l'impact sur des populations
ciblées donc il est sans doute
nécessaire de penser des mesures qui
vont toucher c'est qu'ils sont en
pauvreté énergétique ou c qui à cause de
ces les dernières hausses des prix de
l'énergie ou de la façon vont tomber
dans la dans la pauvreté énergétique
dans la vulnérabilité économique donc il
faut réagir également
certes il y à des sanctions nationales
et internationales mais il ya aussi deux
volants de politiques nationales qui ne
faut jamais oublier et qu'il faut
réactiver parce qu on est plus habitué
en fait à ce type de politique montrer
fort sortir du fameux pacte de stabilité
européen on est déjà sorti alors établir
ce que souhaiteraient les allemands on
est quand même loin du compte jacques
juste à notre conclusion est oui le
pacte de stabilité est provisoirement
mis sous le boisseau les allemands
justement sont le pays charnière parce
que c'était eux qui étaient les garants
de la discipline financière là je crois
et le co vide et maintenant les
sanctions et la politique du gaz vont
les obliger à changer
complètement revoir leur copie et tout
dépendra aussi et je crois que c'est là
c'est important de l'issue de la guerre
la durée de la guerre je crois qu'on va
les français et les allemands
souhaiteraient disant
engagé que les clés que les négociations
sur la paix puisse ou en tout cas sur un
cessez le feu puisse engager parce que
eh bien entendu il espère que ça
limitera la durée 10 ans des retombées
néfastes pour pour les voilà on voit
bien que sur le terrain évidemment on
n'en est pas là remercie beaucoup et
jacques jacques rupnik merci beaucoup
olivier dorgan merci à une critique et
puis merci avoue sylvie matelly d'avoir
été avec nous à merci à vous tous deux
un suivi vous reste avec nous sur france
[Musique]